I don't take the same suggestion twice
because that would be cheating right
what one second one second and what a
real great first suggestion just stray
in just just like racism out of that
yeah straight away won't final rule and
that's an acceptable suggestion I will
grill you further on though whoever here
said racism is a suggestion you know no
that's oh no you don't to apologize for
that I mean it depends what aspect are
you coming from you like it's a great
thing I love it
let's it's a very general topic so let's
let's delve into it like pick an aspect
I mean I think that you know we're gonna
need more than a three minute beat to
tackle that and this is only one of five
topics it is Black History Month yeah
it's true it is the leap dates the is
the once every four years Black History
Month gets one extra day it does feel
unfair that it's the shortest month of
the year doesn't it really
okay cool so let's deal with that I mean
I'll deal with it obviously I feel like
you've just gone yeah handle this white
boy but that's fine
that's a fine suggestion so a history of
racism in America and let's get need for
more suggestions and let's come to you
guys over here what you want to wrap up
have you not heard enough
hip-hop songs about that already I mean
what what let's let's be specific let's
be like pick a position like reverse
cowgirl or be like oh that awkward
moment when you have to check if the
condom still on because you're not sure
you want to be a dad or light layout no
not one that I've said that would go
against the rules guys I know it's late
but step your game up really what what
what's what you want list your asset out
sell out sex ed teaching that's a good
suggestion what's your favorite thing to
well what do you think the most
important thing to teach our kids is in
sex ed safe pornography use guys castle
the show we're all going to learn
something
so say pornography use in the context of
a healthy relationship or just in these
kids lives yeah yeah it's it's a hard
problem that wasn't that wasn't on
purpose guys okay safe pornography use
that is a fantastic suggestion what a
member of you to walk back in we're
discuss we're learning about safe
pornography usage you know you're like I
don't need to learn about that I'm all
real if I know that so we have the
suggestion a history of American racism
safe pornography usage the rest of you
who have to suggests have a real tough
but there's a hand at the back waving
very politely I'll come to you second
what person to back what do you want oh
wow that definitely feels like it comes
from personal experience but then again
you're not wearing all black so I did
use that happen to you yeah you seem
quite cheerful and normal is that yeah
you should meet my brother who growing
up in a funeral home he had a hand up
here someone cutting in line were they
in a wheelchair I don't feel that gives
them a pass they get they get their own
[ __ ] parking spaces they can wait in
line as well plus they get to sit down
as comfy I'm sorry if you're in a
wheelchair but also get the back of the
line right so a history of American
racism safe pornography usage someone
cutting in line per day in a wheelchair
and growing up in a funeral home there's
one suggestion I feel like it should
come from the middle of the room because
you guys have yet whoa one second there
were two at the same time so the the
gentleman said changing a tire you're
quite drunk aren't you you said train
training a tire changing a tire yeah
and one person is super excited about
changing a tire can I just clarify so do
you mean as in a rubber tire on a
vehicle or a tire as in clothes
cool cool change because like Jane Eyre
change of attire could also view when
you go out yeah and I try to check I
didn't want to disappoint you and I'm
like Adam I've got a tuxedo and you're
like yeah I know what Michelin right
there was a woman's voice that said
something as well who thoughts County I
mean that would that's not even a
question is it right
I took it it's a good question maybe
we'll try and fit them yeah I mean that
lady is very adamant that will go with
tire haha I am alby's goatee I like the
county a suggestion but changing a tire
is just because you know I know quite a
lot about Kenya whereas changing a tire
I'm like yeah dad how - how do I find
someone who can do this right okay
this meant to close out the show a real
treat for you guys it's a freestyle rap
that's the rat made up on the spot
facing tallying those suggestions it's
not ever gonna be seen again it's made
up in the moment and it will be about a
history of American racism safe
pornography usage changing a tire maybe
who loves Kanye more than Kanye but
maybe not growing up in a funeral home
and what was our other one that we had
getting cut in line by a wheelchair I
was trying to deliberately forget that
one I was like maybe we don't
because thing is I post I'd post these
online sometimes if I like them and that
was gonna get me a lawyer hate from her
that's okay
I thank you for I love this support you
like my flavor flavor just like you do
this if we am if we can drop the beat
good sir let's let's have some fun with
this
I'm excited honest a new beat as well
I'm excited and more little volume as
well try to I don't know where the drop
is on this one I should've listened to
it before we did it okay so can we
rewind oh I want to hit that drop train
I'm like super pro it's cuz I mix up the
beat each time and then okay right so
which one to start with
I'm gonna go with the lady in the back
yeah lady is the black not dawn dawn in
black she could change that attire if
you gave her a brat growing up a funeral
home plain to see a chill lady loving
mortuary assisting a dad when it comes
to the chloroform put formaldehyde there
and I look at all the corpses lying up
inside the morgue in the funeral home
yeah you feel the door there's so much
death but so much love as well Six Feet
Under
cast me in this spell i watch the
television series dude with the guy from
Dexter Michael C Hall yeah Wikipedia
check yeah I know their names like I'm
IMDB who when I wake up in the morning I
see people I see dead there cultist
touch and flowers in the vars people
walking into all the poor where dodge
away there was maybe at the back is like
this was my childhood
did you enjoy yeah it was Wow good it
was amazing it couldn't have got any
sillier and lesser surgery in loading in
necrophilia but given do that sick in
the head you think you going in there
and have a date with the dead a day in
the dead my dear drill us watch us in
Mexico a big problem in this country yo
racism more blacks than whites in prison
a real problem ever since the year oh
it's 1616 who the first slave ship came
across bear transported from the
Atlantic you a whole nation will on the
blacks and slaves no reparations even to
this very day the third eat amendment
throwing guys in prison is basically
slavery Republicans say it isn't it
doesn't matter though the beats not long
enough my knowledge of this history is
not strong enough but we need to come
out from all fronts on the very last day
of Black History Month but um you know
the no doubt it's what we do if you're
in the wheelchair yeah I'd get you it
must have sucked but you lost the use of
your legs it must be horrible you need a
bedpan in your bed but still man when
will you learn I've got wheels and I'm
live still wait your turn this is a
whole damn line I'm looking at you you
need to wheel right there to the back of
the queue everybody feels like you get
the sympathy vote now you get concession
tickets yeah you get on votes for
cheaper then everybody else has got to
pay I said it only cried I ruined his
day because we're at Disneyland he's
only seven years old
make-a-wish child and I still give him
scold James and say now I don't give a
[ __ ] you are not getting to shake Mickey
Mouse or Donald Duck that way in here
he's quiet like a fountain when I'm
riding high having fun on Space Mountain
the best place for me to be let me talk
about the rapper and his plane to see
he's insane you know he's going off his
rocker who thinks he's amazing and wise
let's stop there from Star Trek but I'll
say today no one loves Kanye more than
Kanye loves Kanye he loves himself and
it is not good I know these days we say
we need self-love you need to self care
practice it and take a day off now can
you really ask your professor of mental
health what is wrong with you well he
prescribed lexapro it's what you do with
your the
at supper form anxiety still 10 years
ago it was easy to proclaim him as a
genius who we can answer me
best cameo album uh Dark Twisted Fantasy
we know that stuff some people say no it
doesn't please us it wants to drop out
or yeezus we need to want more I'm
holding yours to end what was the
suggestion we got from these friends
what was the one the cosmic now on okay
no I'm not me - come on I'll ask a lot
funnier this one's less fun I would be
boasting I make it up I'd be a liar if I
said I'd ever encounter changing the car
tires I just sit there and pull out my
insurance plan and wait there triple-a
before a much better man he walks up he
says Chris is not there I wasn't aware
that in my blue I didn't even have a
spare
I Drive a BMW 3 Series with the
run-flats I really worry yeah you know I
shouldn't have done that
I shouldn't have stopped her should the
drove it home put it in the garage over
here you say Garrett and I'm living it
largely because I'm changing tires from
front to back I rotate them at the place
they put it on the jack they lift it up
and then they change the oil while away
now guys take care every time you
masturbate it's really cool you gotta
educate the kids so it comes to porn and
they're not addicted because it's so
pervasive you're pulling out your phone
then pop pots for advertisements wanking
off at home ladies in your area who want
to hook up with you and when you're
horny and you're 13 what the [ __ ] you're
going to do you're gonna get really
wrecked to say yeah ladies are no longer
respect them cause my whole idea and sex
has been turned rough because they get
it in the newsfeed so much enough they
see crazy stuff like porn that is snuff
that's where you kill someone when
you've had the sex in the buff
so crazy and it can't be easy to be the
person who's acting is the teacher
trying to get attention of the back of
the class beaker over there run the
[ __ ] jacking off in an asset is so a
horrible you go if you have to envision
that coming over here no there's no
revision of that it's not homework when
you're home then you jerk and then you
clean it up after all the kids squirt
and obviously I'm just focusing on the
guys because to talk about the ladies
would not be fair in your eyes
that's basically your curriculum right
curriculum without calm